en principio le pregunto Quiénes son los
migrantes que están varados Y de dónde
provienen y Hacia dónde se dirigen
aproximadamente
confusa no no olvide usted que la gran
nación venezolana alcanzó los siete
millones cien mil personas de las cuales
un millón quinientas mil están en el
Perú siete millones setecientos mil en
Colombia 500 mil en chile y unos 460 mil
en el Ecuador de tal manera Este es un
pequeño problema de un gran problema que
hasta el día de hoy no se resuelve y no
se resuelve porque no hay coordinación
entre los ministerios de relaciones
exteriores la dirección de migraciones
de los países correspondientes y
naturalmente órganos especializados como
acnur Este es un hecho lamentable que
demuestran negligencia y descoordinación
diplomática entre dos países fronterizos
como Perú y chile que tienen atrapados
en la línea de fronteras se estima unos
doscientos a 25 en esa zona donde hay
mujeres embarazadas niños mayor ancianos
que no pueden entrar a Chile pero
tampoco pueden entrar al Perú están en
la tierra de nadie entonces acá lo que
se requiere es una gran coordinación una
digamos una mesa de diálogo no solo
entre chile y el Perú sino también entre
Colón chile Perú Colombia y Ecuador y
naturalmente la participación de
Venezuela que ya debió haber enviado
aviones tanto a tacna como arica para
que se puedan retirar sus ciudadanos Yo
quiero recordarles que salieron de
Venezuela
Víctimas de una crisis terrible pero que
debo recordar también que el actual
mandatario el señor maduro ofreció el
famoso plan Retorno a la patria que
significa darle todas las facilidades a
sus compatriotas para que regresen a su
país esto hasta el momento no ha
ocurrido no hemos escuchado ni por asomo
la voz de maduro
bueno el ministro del interior peruano
aseguró que ambos países trabajan en
Establecer un corredor humanitario pero
es para solucionar la situación es esa
la respuesta adecuada si tenemos en
cuenta que el tránsito de migrantes por
esa zona es algo habitual
yo no entiendo que es un corredor
humanitario porque hay gente que ha
propuesto inclusive ese corrector
signifique trasladarlos desde estándar
hasta hasta tumbes y de tumbes al
Ecuador lo cual me parece realmente
no quiero calificarlo porque de tacna a
tumbes son dos mil cuatrocientos
cincuenta kilómetros usted se imagina
docenas de ómnibuses trasladando esa
gente donde hay niños mujeres
embarazadas enfermos no acompañados de
de patrullas motorizadas de la policía o
del ejército y de ahí cuando terminan de
recorrer esos dos mil cuatrocientos
cincuenta kilómetros tendrán que seguir
otro tramo enorme hacia el Ecuador y
llega hacia Venezuela no entonces una
una digamos una realidad yo lo que creo
Es que ya ha llegado la hora que
las cancillerías se sienten que
comprendan que este es un problema
humanitario de alto nivel y que más allá
de este incidente Más allá de este
incidente encuentre una respuesta global
al problema migratorio porque siguen
saliendo de acuerdo a los reportes de
Naciones Unidas más o menos entre mil y
mil doscientos venezolanos siguen
saliendo a su país O sea que eso no
termina es la crisis más severa por la
cual atravesaba América Latina y
evidentemente las consecuencias la están
pagando los migrantes y todos nuestros
países